That's because even though people like you
who are young
and healthy will probably not get sick from
this,
this is really not something that's scary
for you,
there are people who could potentially become
sick,
right?
And, so we're talking about people who are
older,
or people who are already sick with other
types of things, like someone who might have
cancer
and is on special kinds of medicines, their
immune systems are kind of like not really
working great.
And, so the reason why we're not going to
places where there are lots of people that
could
gather on an inside, is to make sure we're
not spreading the disease to people-- the
virus-- to
people who could get really sick from it.
So, people who don't have very good immune
systems right now.
And, so we're actually doing this
so that we can protect the people around us,
and I think that's a really important thing
for humans to do, is to protect each other,
right?
And, that's one of the ways that we're doing
it.
And, it also helps our hospitals by making
sure that people are
reducing the amount of exposure to other people.
It'll help our hospitals be able to handle
taking care of the people who are actually
sick from this.
And, so we're helping doctors
and we’re helping nurses and we're helping
healthcare professionals by making sure
that they are not going to be like bombarded
with patients.
So, it's really important that we do this.
And it's hard.
It's hard not to be with our friends,
but it's one of the biggest helpers that we
can do in our community.